sommes là pour pouvoir répondre aux
besoins et aux attentes des chercheurs
et des chefs chinois et vient vraiment
je devrais de l'action à mener
il ya vraiment à réveiller cette commune
comme on dit nous les fêtes chez
cheville mossé batko politique qui n'est
pas qu'il laisse pas indifférent vous
étiez là déjà dès le début avec alfred
almont vous l'avez rappelé ce soir et
vous avez dit que vous restez votre
engagement est toujours aussi important
qu'au début oui effectivement j'étais
engagé en politique depuis 2001 et est
depuis 2008 je suis dans l'opposition
mais j'aime à dire dans cette opposition
j'ai toujours été présent dans la
commune
j'ai toujours participé aux conseils
municipaux pour pouvoir me m'intéresser
à ce qui se passe au mas commune et
aujourd'hui je pense que j'ai
l'expérience je vis la commune je
connais bien tous je dirais toutes les
infrastructures tout et structures tout
ce qui se passe ces quartiers de
chercher et c'est pour ça qu'aujourd'hui
nous avons un vrai plan d'action que
nous voulons mettre en place pour
pouvoir proposer au chef choisit ses
choix et nous pensons après tout le
porte à porte on a fait que nous allons
pouvoir bien répondre à leurs besoins
il y a
il y a quelques années en fait par
rapport aux dernières élections là vous
reveniez encore différemment avec avec
on va dire plus fraîches avec une vision
plus fraîches aussi par rapport à par
rapport à 2014 c'est vrai j'ai dit j'ai
pris de l'expérience et je pense que le
projet aujourd'hui il est bien mûri j'ai
rencontré aussi plus de monde
g j'ai rencontré la population j'ai pris
plus de temps aller à la rencontre des
gens et pour pouvoir vraiment
m'imprégner de mes différents quartiers
pour pouvoir avoir un programme qui
colle je dirais aux attentes des chaînes
chinoises et des chefs chinois